vous dites jeûner le 17 juin 1792 à
Saint-Denis il est 9h30 ma vie commence
dans l'hôpital le plus sordide du 93 mon
sang est sale héroïne craque shit que ma
mère Fabienne a consommé pendant sa
grossesse
c'est un film tous les jours c'est une
série Netflix je me réveille le matin je
me dis ok aujourd'hui je dois gérer quoi
la tentative de suicide de ma mère là
elle allait la chercher dans un parc
public le jour de la Toussaint de la
trouver en cellule dégrisement trois
tentatives de suicide en l'espace de
deux semaines vous dites que votre mère
vendait du crack sur prostituer et
vendez également des montres volées
c'est la vérité parce que
malheureusement ma mère a beaucoup
souffert dans sa vie et à subit
l'inceste et ma grand-mère n'a pas
divorcé de cet homme qui lui a fait
subir ça donc ben elle est partie vivre
en fait à Saint-Denis à la croisée
malheureusement bah une mauvaise
personne mon père et je comprends mieux
aujourd'hui et je l'explique très bien
justement dans l'ouvrage que je n'ai pas
croisé mon père pour certaines raisons
et notamment le fait que c'est lui qui a
injecté ma mère pendant qu'il était
enceinte de moi
donc voilà c'est un départ dans la vie
qui est assez difficile et c'est
difficile au quotidien de se relever et
justement quand on arrive à faire de la
télé-réalité on se dit super je vais
pouvoir sortir de la précarité je vais
pouvoir m'en sortir je vais pouvoir
faire ce que j'aime c'est à dire de la
musique ce qui m'a sauvé la vie
clairement parce que pour moi là c'est
quelque chose qui sauve la vie et ça
devrait être d'ailleurs gratuit pour
énormément de jeunes qui sont
défavorisés et voilà on va revenir sur
sur le livre vous êtes vous allez chez
votre grand-mère mais autre problème
votre grand-mère elle a un compagnon qui
s'appelle Bruno
et dans le réfrigérateur des étiquettes
sont collées sur les aliments B pour
Bruno aime pour Madeleine personne est
autorisé à manger la nourriture de
Monsieur lorsqu'il accompagne Madeleine
en voiture il lui fait payer tous les
déplacements comme un taxi c'est
incroyable et dernière vous dites Bruno
se promène nu même lorsque ma copine
Coralie vient à la maison il me demande
souvent pourquoi je ne montre pas mon
abricot pendant les vacances scolaires
il nous amène dans des camps naturistes
nous contraignant à suivre les règles du
camping le malaise et palpable
c'est quand même tout parce que elle
part de chez sa mère elle va chez sa
grand-mère et là ça continue et vous
arrivez à l'école au collège et vous
êtes victime de harcèlement collège on
vous casse votre casier vous humilier à
la cantine
pourquoi pourquoi vous étiez dans cette
situation parce que j'étais la fille de
personne donc déjà quand on arrivait en
classe c'est qu'on avait les fiches à
l'époque scolaire où on devait mettre le
nom de sa mère et le nom de son père
bien moi je disais d'accord mais moi je
n'ai pas mes parents donc en fait je
dois noter quoi et quand je disais ma
grand-mère j'étais La Bâtarde la fille
de personnes en plus de ça j'avais déjà
des critiques sur mon sur mon physique à
l'époque ou sur ma voix parce que je
chantais déjà dans les toilettes
voilà c'était ma façon en fait de de
vivre et de trouver un second souffle et
de palier en fait à tous ces traumas
parce que justement quand je rentrais
chez moi je voyais un homme qui était nu
parce que je voyais ma grand-mère
souffrir parce que je voyais ma mère
malade aussi qui a eu l'hépatite et j'ai
dû porter tout ça et donc oui la vie
c'est c'est beaucoup de choses et
justement malheureusement pour moi j'ai
subi avant la télé le harcèlement déjà
et c'est en ça que j'aimerais dire quand
même à toutes les personnes qui sont à
l'école et qui sont en cours que en fait
pour moi c'est loin d'être des victimes
parce que se lever tous les matins et
avoir courage d'aller affronter des gens
qui harcèlent au quotidien et
aujourd'hui avec justement le smartphone
les réseaux sociaux les médias etc c'est
un 360 infernal et le harcèlement il est
permanent avant on pouvait couper
jusqu'à ce smartphone alors vous sortez
en boîte un soir vous prenez des photos
pour vous créer un book et là un agent
vous contacte il vous propose d'être
modèle c'est ça oui d'accord mais encore
une malédiction votre agent vous enferme
chez lui pendant plusieurs heures
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé oui je suis
tombé sur un malade c'était sur book.fr
et d'ailleurs il y avait eu aussi
beaucoup de gens qui ont été séquestrés
même il y a eu des crimes sur sur
book.fr et donc
pour moi ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'il
me propose en fait de venir le
rencontrer sur Paris donc je monte avec
ma grand-mère je le rends compte
professionnel parfait et cette personne
là en fait avait déjà agressé d'autres
modèles et il m'avait dit non mais avant
qu'on aille faire le casting de ça on va
passer chez moi vite le machin il m'a
enfermé il a pris il a cassé la glace de
chez lui en fait son miroir et c'est
ouvert le visage devant moi j'ai dû
hurler et ça a été très dur et très dur
pour moi la police a débarqué etc donc
c'est incroyable alors
quand vous en sortez en fait de cette
histoire vous partez la police arrive
parce qu'en fait les voisins montant de
hurler
vous créez ensuite une page Facebook et
là des castors vous contactent vous avez
des propositions pour plusieurs
émissions
j'en avais enfin j'avais eu popstar
Nouvelle Star enfin j'en avais eu
vraiment énormément mais ma grand-mère à
l'époque justement ne voulait pas du
tout que je fasse de téléréalité et vous
devenez gogo danseuse c'est ça entre
temps en fait je j'arrête l'école quand
j'ai 16 ans et je fais l'Académie
Internationale de Danse de Paris et je
fais aussi les Cours Florent ainsi que
l'école Atlas à Pigalle et donc à la
suite de ça malheureusement je me blesse
et vu que j'avais pas d'argent et que je
mangeais avec un euro pour trois jours
et bien quand je me blesse ma grand-mère
elle me dit il faut rentrer dans le sud
de la France parce que tu peux pas on
peut pas continuer de vivre comme ça
j'avais pas de chauffage je dormais avec
ma gardienne d'ailleurs Fatima
franchement merci
pour ces moments parce que c'était
tellement difficile
donc voilà je rentre dans le sud et là
je me dis j'ai pas j'ai arrêté l'école
j'ai pas de bac j'ai rien qu'est-ce que
je peux faire et on me contacte par
rapport à mon physique et on me dit bah
voilà je vais être gogo dancing je vais
être strip-teaseuse et j'essaie de m'en
sortir comme je peux en fait pour
pouvoir manger et aider ma famille vous
rencontrez ensuite un homme qui
s'appelle Baptiste
vous rencontrez où
sur Facebook à l'époque juste au début
du lancement de cette plateforme mais
même avec lui ça se passe mal aussi bien
parce que justement le fait d'avoir
manqué d'un père toute ma vie et de
jamais avoir pu dire papa j'ai été je
pense vu que je suis hyper sensible et
en pâte et ben attiré par ce genre de
personne toxiques en fait qui vous
vampirise et qui avait à chaque fois
disons 15 ans de plus que moi parce que
je pense que malgré tout inconsciemment
je cherchais le père que j'avais pas eu
vous le quittez
et vous entrez ensuite dans la
télé-réalité vous gagnez très bien votre
vie dans la télé la téléréalité un nom
quand on démarre on sait très bien en
tant que nouveau dans les Marseillais on
gagne 3000 euros par quoi
3000 euros le tournage entier en tant
que nouveau c'est combien de temps le
tournage c'était presque deux mois
d'accord
vous êtes logés pour moi c'était énorme
oui voilà mais ça pour moi une jeune de
21 ans
pour moi je veux dire ça me parle 3000
euros après c'est monté après forcément
tournage 12000 euros et comme vous le
savez tous je pense j'ai fait un procès
pour faire respecter mes droits
d'artistes et j'ai gagné d'accord donc
on va dire que c'était pas non plus
incroyable ça vous plaisait la
téléréalité
ce qui me plaisait c'était le rêve en
fait qu'on m'a vendu c'était quoi le
rêve qu'on vous a vendu de pouvoir enfin
faire de la musique et de faire ce que
j'aime et pouvoir vraiment gagner ma vie
en prenant du plaisir quand 99 autres
pour cent de la vie c'est de la torture
et de voir gérer sa famille
alors vous dites que la télé-réalité
vous a aussi fait penser à suicide je
faisais pensé à vous suicider il y a 8
ans vous voulez même vous tuer en
voiture c'est ça pourquoi parce que je
pense que les gens se rendent pas compte
que en fait
un acte c'est un acte qui est en fait
avec les réseaux sociaux et toute l'air
médiatique actuelle digitale etc qui est
poursuivi dans le temps on revoit les
replays en fait toute notre vie on va
être quoi en fait une fille bimbo et
cervelet qui a rien à raconter qui s'est
fait harceler qui a une grosse bouche
énorme qui se fait insulter dans la rue
voire ma grand-mère qui en souffre non
je suis plus que ça je suis un être
humain et je mérite le respect comme
n'importe qui en fait donc toute ma vie
je dois prouver deux fois plus déjà que
je devais prouver énormément du fait que
j'avais pas eu de parents et que j'avais
pas confiance en moi et que je m'aimais
pas et là en plus de ça le peu de choses
que j'ai réussi à mettre en place et il
a peu de construction humaine que j'ai
réussi à faire et bah on me l'a détruit
en fait
je voulais me tuer en voiture qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé mais en fait ça se
décide pas c'est des pulsions vous savez
c'est en voiture et vous êtes dit je
vais quoi je vais foncer contre un mur
je vais faire quoi oui j'écoutais de la
musique j'étais à 200 sur une route à
Montpellier avec des platanes et je me
le disais pourquoi je vis en fait
pourquoi être là mais même aujourd'hui
je vous le déris là je suis là parce que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui j'ai des
messages à faire passer pour ma
grand-mère mais sinon moi j'ai pas de
tentative de suicide vous savez et je
trouve ça très péjoratif de dire
tentative parce qu'en fait quand on en
est là on a plus envie de vivre et on
n'est pas là pour tenter en fait on fait
tout pour y arriver moi
j'avais vraiment rien à perdre quand
j'ai fait tout ça et tout était très
bien pensé je vous le dis j'avais mes
dernières volontés sur mon ordinateur
j'avais les codes de bancaire j'avais
écrit les messages à mes amis pour leur
dire de s'occuper de ma grand-mère de
faire si ça ça et c'était pas un c'est
pas une tentative quand on en peut plus
de vivre on n'en peut plus de vivre
parce que justement tous les jours on
porte énormément de choses et les gens
le savent pas et je suis loin d'être une
bimbo télé-réalité ou autre et loin
d'être la vitrine qu'on voit sur
Instagram qui rigole et qui essaye de
positiver de donner de la goût de vibe
parce que en fait aujourd'hui j'ai
compris que si j'avais que touché le
ciel et que j'étais revenue ici c'est
pour aider des gens comme moi qui sont
appelés tous les jours de victimes alors
qu'ils sont survivants
sur la télé-réalité puisque vous étiez
plusieurs télé-réalités Aurélie si vous
nous rejoignez les 20h49 on est en
direct ça touche pas à mon poste et on
part du livre d'Aurélie et cette
candidat de téléréalité qui a subi
énormément de harcèlement dans la
télé-réalité vous dites il me jette des
sauts de javel mais des lézards morts
sur mon lit
urine sur mon matelas qu'il traîne dans
le jardin l'injustice la cruauté
sont-elles que je ne parviens pas à
réaliser ce qui m'arrive bien sûr est-ce
qu'on vous a fait on vous a fait c'est
ce qu'on nous a fait pire ça c'est
incroyable pourquoi
il faisait ça dans le dans
sincèrement qu'en fait c'est juste
l'environnement actuel c'est à dire il y
a de la violence c'est toujours plus
trash il y a plus de cadre l'être humain
n'a plus de cadre aujourd'hui et en fait
on se perd et tout le monde se perd et
en fait on a juste amené un climat
exceptionnel pour la méchanceté et la
violence voilà en fait et le le schéma
de la téléréalité quand on regarde
vraiment psychologiquement tout le
travail et tout ce que ça amène après
sur les générations
le sadisme le voyeurisme la
transposition en psychologie je suis
passionné de psychologie je vous le dis
c'est dingue et donc oui ces émissions
là elles veulent quoi elles veulent
aller toujours plus loin en pensant que
ça va faire de l'audience manque de bol
pour eux manque de vol pour eux à la
suite de ma saison et bien ça c'est
effondré parce que il y a quand même des
gens qui restent humains et qui ne sont
pas prêts à tout en fait voilà prêt à
tout on détruit pas un être humain on le
linge pas publiquement parce que là pour
moi c'est vraiment détruire l'âme d'une
personne détruire sa personnalité et que
des éditos et des gens acceptent ça et
même des journalistes qui acceptent de
monter des émissions comme ça quand ils
sont quand les cartes SD sont envoyées à
Paris je trouve ça scandaleux vraiment
et ils ont juste de la chance et je le
dis aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque je n'avais
pas les moyens financiers de pouvoir
attaquer sur ça aussi parce que sinon je
me serais fait un malin plaisir et je
trouve ça juste dommage parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a encore eu
énormément de gens qui ont souffert de
ça d'ailleurs vous en avez reçu
plusieurs d'autres candidats qui ont
souffert de ça et ça fait juste sept ans
en fait et qu'est-ce qui se passe rien
pour moi il devrait y avoir des modéra
des modérateurs qui regarderaient les
épisodes de certaines émissions avant
qu'elles soient diffusées alors vous
avez publié une photo choc sur insta
c'était quand cette photo c'est un mois
d'août au mois d'août posiez combien de
kilos aujourd'hui 16 aujourd'hui j'en
fais 43 qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous
avez repris un petit peu du poil de la
bête comme on dit des gens super
alu harpe à l'hôpital de Montpellier
d'ailleurs je leur dis merci ce qui
m'ont vraiment aidé et Magalie aussi qui
était avec moi en réanimation à Toulon
enfin voilà c'est
une infirmière qui était avec moi en
réanimation et je l'embrasse très fort
Aurélien vous sent très triste quand
vous parlez de tout ça c'est normal
aujourd'hui vous êtes dans quel état
d'esprit est-ce que vous êtes vous dites
je vais remonter la pente ou est-ce que
vous dites moi pour moi mon destin c'est
que du malheur je me dis juste
aujourd'hui que j'ai plus rien à perdre
en fait j'ai 30 ans j'ai rien à perdre
je passe mon temps à me documenter à
essayer de faire ce que j'aime à essayer
de sortir ma famille comme je peux ma
grand-mère était hospitalisée d'ailleurs
je veux juste lui faire un petit coucou
parce que je sais qu'elle nous regarde
et ça me touche beaucoup
je t'aime très fort
et je trouve ça inhumain
où on est content après quand
voulez-vous réinsérer dans la vie moi je
voulais vendre mes réseaux sociaux
essayez de faire de l'immobilier je suis
parti en Suisse j'ai passé des super
examens j'avais 20 sur 20 on m'a dit non
vous êtes une personnalité publique vous
pouvez pas faire travailler dans les
assurances
des référencement que vous payez des
avocats ensemble vous dites quoi non
vous êtes un personnage public vous êtes
un personnage public avant d'être un
être humain
et c'est quoi en fait ma vie c'est de
passer toute ma vie pour une personne
qui a eu aussi une poupée gonflable sur
un plateau télé avec sa photo dessus
c'est ça c'est ça Aurélie dans la vie de
tous les jours non Aurélie c'est une
battante c'est une fille qui se lève
tous les jours et que c'est qui sait
pourquoi et là et qu'elle en veut et
justement quand j'ai voulu arrêter de
vivre c'est parce que le 1 % qui m'a
toujours raccroché à la vie quand on m'a
dit tu as fait de la télé tu signeras
jamais en maison de disques et ben j'ai
fait le 1 % et j'ai signé en maison de
disquet j'ai monté mon propre label et
j'ai toujours été comme ça et bah là le
1% il y a un mois et demi il existait
plus simplement
vous regrettez d'avoir fait de la
téléréalité bien sûr je regrette mais
c'est c'est
je dirais pas que c'est la plus grosse
erreur que j'ai pu faire mais je pensais
pas arriver dans un système comme ça et
aujourd'hui je suis juste contente de
voir que certaines émissions n'existent
plus et je suis juste heureuse de voir
qu'il y a de la prévention ça marche
plus du tout aujourd'hui la télé
en fait ça va ça va mourir gentiment
exactement mais on veut du
divertissement on veut on veut de la on
veut de la joie de vivre en fait et puis
je suis désolé mais on est tous des
êtres humains quand on critique
quelqu'un sur son physique le soir on va
se coucher on se dit ah super donc j'ai
fait souffrir une personne aujourd'hui
wow moi si j'ai fait du mal à quelqu'un
je suis mal le soir dans mon lit ici
nous il nous arrive de vanner on va pas
se mentir aussi on se battre voilà tous
ici mais bon c'était pas de la vanne
c'était quoi
l'attente à la personne ça fait écho
d'ailleurs au documentaire qu'on voit
après
le livre d'Aurélie Preston Brésil brisé
merci Aurélie
merci on vous souhaite
relâchez rien